[Music]
let's play d4
okay let's play catalan i i really don't
mind i do play the catalan i mean i i
have played it before
now assuming the black yep okay so so we
play the catalan
and maybe that way i'll talk a little
bit about the white side of the can now
again i'm not too qualified to talk
about this i've played the catalan a
fair amount of times for both colors
okay so this is the main line a6 okay a6
so a6 is the first surprise
the sort of traditional main line is d
takes c4 in this position and i'll show
you this after the game but dc is the
most popular line a6
clearly prepares dc
it's clear to me that black is preparing
to take on c4 and to follow that up with
the move b5 so it is worthwhile in this
position to protect the c4 pawn and if
you study the catalan you will know that
the way that you normally protect that
pawn the first
line of defense
is the move queen to c2 because this
doesn't obstruct
the development
of the other pieces so knight c6 is
already kind of a mistake i think knight
c6 prevents black from ever being able
to push the c pawn we just talked about
this and it gives us like an ideal
catalan structure okay so the other good
thing about playing queen c2 is that it
vacates the d1 square and it's a very
good idea in the catalan to put a rook
on d1 even if the center does not open
you have to make sure that your d4 pawn
is well defended so
i like the idea of playing rook d1 in
this position
notice how we're delaying the
development of our king side
excuse me of our queen side pieces
because i don't know yet exactly where i
want to put the bishop and the knight i
want to see
how black positions his pieces first
okay knight before well knight b4 is not
scary we're just gonna play queen b3
my guess is that black is gonna take and
go b5 maybe i shouldn't have allowed
that i don't know
b5 yeah
i suppose that
i should have maybe played
i should have maybe played knight b to
d2
actually to meet dc with knight takes c4
somehow i this escaped my my attention
it's not the end of the world we go
queen back to b3
we just get a normal catalan position i
think white is still a little better
okay so now let's get the night out
now now it's obvious where we need to
develop right now and here it's obvious
that we don't want to go knight bd2
that's a ridiculous move
so we go knight c3
and very often in these types of
positions the battle revolves around the
question of whether black will be able
to push c5 like if black pushes c5
and trades the d4 pawn for the c5 pawn
the position is at the very least going
to be equal if black does not manage to
do it the c pawn becomes backward and
our control of the center is superior
right because we have a pawn in the
center and black doesn't
so
you get this very complex positional
battle where black tries to get c5 and
white makes all these moves to prevent
c5 sometimes you see the bishop even
coming out to e3 in these positions
don't be surprised if you do that's a
way to discourage c5 knight d5 by our
opponent okay
so
we should keep a couple of things in
mind we need to prevent c5 at all costs
not at all costs but like
it would would not be very good if black
got a chance to play this move
so let's think about how we can
how we can do that well i've got an idea
and i'm borrowing from what i know about
the catalan
because taking on d5 makes some sense
here no e4 is bad if e4 is bad because
black takes on c3 and then you drop the
pawn
yeah knight e5 is really interesting but
i'm afraid that black can simplify with
knight takes c3 and i'm not
overly enthralled with that my
inclination was to play bishop g5
yeah a4 is interesting too but then
black can play b4
i would like us to play bishop g5 now
this is a development developing move
but essentially how am i trying to
discourage c5 what i'm trying to do is
to take on f6 at some point
and my point is that black's bishop is
going to be overloaded the bishop
defends c5 the bishop also defends f6
and if after c5 bishop takes f6
knight takes f6 then we can take on c5
with a discovery i think h6 is
inaccurate
and what we're gonna do is actually take
this knight on f6 preemptively bishop
takes f6
and what very nice positional move
are we going to play now again
we are trying to focus all of our energy
on preventing c5 if possible once and
for all we go 94 and now we have an
advantage no question about it bishop
takes f6 was a mistake
and we're going to go rook ac1 and we're
going to stick a knight on c5 and we are
going to pressure black down the c file
for the rest of the game
this is where the catalan gets to be
such a nasty opening to face when you
get a position like this which i've
gotten before
the other knight by the way can jump out
to e5 absolutely
can jump out to e5
and then maybe even to c6
so again just like in the previous game
with that move bishop g6 right we don't
necessarily rush with knight c5 we can
play that move when we want to play it
we have done the job of preventing black
from playing c5
so on the next move it would make sense
for us to also consider the move knight
e5 as i was saying
knight b6
okay well now that kind of forces our
hand
that kind of forces our hand it forces
us to make a decision between knight c5
and but what i really like is the move
knight e5
i love the move knight e5 because it
defends the knight with the bishop
and it piles on the pressure it
activates the other knight
and we are not really afraid of bishop
d5 which i would imagine black will play
and bishop d5 just attacks the queen but
we can drop the queen back to c2
and obviously the a2 pawn is going to be
untouchable there because we have b3
trapping the bishop
yeah so also notice how we are
restricting black's knight and not
permitting it to jump out to c4 not that
that would be such a dangerous move
anyway but
still
no if black plays f5 i mean that's
unthinkable because the e6 pawn is going
to hang with check bishop d5 there we go
so let's drop our queen back to c2
drop our queen back to c2
we are threatening now to capture on c7
and everything in the catalan happens
slowly right you're we're not going to
win this game in two seconds black is
still quite solid
but you can see how much he's suffering
knight c4 okay now it's time for us to
transform our advantage the big question
is should we take on c4
we have an interesting alternative we
have several interesting alternatives
but to my eyes the answer
probably is yes because black is no good
way to recapture bc come on look at
these weaknesses
but we need to be very precise here and
here's the thing my initial idea is to
say okay
this pawn on c4 seems to be black's
weakest pawn
so if you think about how to attack it
you get the idea of moving the knight
back to d2
but if you calculate concretely after
knight d2 what happens there is a flaw
with that move
there's a flaw with that move black
takes on g2
and then our pawn on d4 is going to be
hanging because we're intercepting the
rook's connection to that pawn so rather
than getting discouraged we just ask
ourselves can we troubleshoot that at
the start of the line so that we don't
have to deal with the hanging d4 pawn
well the answer to that question is yes
we just play the move e3
and on the next move we are going to
drop the knight back to d2
we are not afraid of bishop takes e4 i
know some of you might think well it
can't black take the knight yeah but
then we just take back and the c4 pawn
is even weaker in that instance so the
movie three very patient prophylactic
move and a preparatory move
and hopefully my moves are making sense
so far at a high level
this is why i i hesitate to play an
opening like the catalan on the speed
run because it's so conceptually
complicated
that
like even i don't understand you know 90
of the main ideas
there is now queen d7 to defend the pawn
queen d7 doesn't defend the pawn okay
rook b8
so black aims at the b2 pawn i don't
think that's this move actually does
anything though
so i think we can very safely drop the
knight back to d2
oh we are definitely willing to trade
bishops i i don't mind trading bishops
our king
is going to be fine
black remember has almost no pieces left
i mean there are no minor pieces left so
trading the catalan bishop is not as
uncommon as you might think this is fine
and you should never make a move just
because like oh i don't like trading
this particular type of piece you should
consider it more concretely
another thing that we should
troubleshoot
we should understand
that if black keeps the status quo if
black makes a move like queen d7
it might not be the wisest idea
to take on c4 immediately we should at
least calculate it before we play that
move because if imagine that in this
position it was white to move and we
would play knight takes c4 black can
take that knight and after queen takes
c4 black can take the pawn on b2
restoring material equality but now that
i think about that line in that final
position after rook takes b2
which pawn can white take
and there's one pawn that you should
take and one pawn that you should not
which pawn should we take in that
position
yes we should take the pawn on a6 for
two reasons the first is that it gives
us an outside passer
and a very very scary one at that the
second is that queen takes c7 allows
rook takes a2 and black seems to keep
the balance there
does that make sense so we are indeed
threatening to take on c4 with the
knight there's very little that black
can do about that
i mean i would if i were black i would
consider the move a5
which is a crazy prophylactic move but
you understand hopefully why
i would consider it
because then after knight c4 bishop c4
queen c4 b2 the pawn is not capturable
so think about what white might do if
black plays a5 he doesn't play it he
takes it goes queen d5 and that's like
clearly a a
you know a defeated a defeated type of
sequence because now he's going to lose
this pawn
and the other queen side pawns are going
to be in bad shape as well
and what stands before us now is just a
pretty straightforward conversion
no we're we're doing fantastic this is
like a catalan player's dream probably
c5 is the lesser evil for black black
should play c5 at least you might get
rid of another weakness because
if we take on c4 and black still has
this pawn
sitting there we might actually win a
second pawn shortly thereafter what i
often find at these levels is that once
you lose upon you know once one side
starts to decline you know it doesn't
take long for more mistakes to appear on
the board
but kudos to our opponent c5 is played
let's play dc opening up the d file
first and foremost and then take on c4
on the next move
and we will have simply a two on one on
the queen side and that will be that
black is also getting quite low on time
okay if bishop c5
we can even consider an id4 but okay i
don't see a point of that i think we
should just play knight take c4
i've never played the catalan before in
a speed run so i hope you're enjoying
this little foray into
the forbidden opening
yeah and i'll go over some of the
typical ideas after the game as well
because i really only glanced through
some of the main the core the core
concepts even if you don't play the
catalan even if you're not a d4 player i
i would suggest that you listen
carefully because
you know these are foundational
positional ideas that you really need to
learn
you know if you want to be a good
positional player and you know some
people advocate the slightly radical
approach of actually choosing an opening
that you don't like
and playing it for a couple of months
deliberately in order to force yourself
to learn
a bunch of important positional ideas i
don't think you should go that far
but this is kind of the same
style
yeah i've heard that recommended by some
coaches actually knight takes c4
now we're gonna win this on time i can
sense that black is not aware of his
clock
okay rook fc8
okay so what should we do here well here
i think that what we should say is okay
our knight on c4 is very nice it's it's
a good night it's sort of controlling a
lot of the queen side squares we
shouldn't move the knight let's defend
it you guys are on the ball b3 is a good
solid sort of russian schoolboy kind of
move now we don't have to worry about
any tactics connected with the knight
and we're our next move if given the
opportunity is going to be rook to d7
we're going to start infiltrating you
know winding our tentacles around
black's position
okay a5 so clearly black is trying to
play a4
that's not particularly scary i mean b
takes a4 would be possible there but
that would remove the defender of the
knight
i wouldn't play a4 here because that
that creates a big weakness on b3
so
let's think for a second i have an
interesting idea
i would like to find a prophylactic move
against a4 i wouldn't necessarily want
to oh
i have a really cool concept
i have a really cool idea
we're going to play the move a weird
weird looking move queen d2
okay so you should see that you're
attacking the a5 pawn i really hope that
black plays a4 here because i have a
super cool response in mind to that move
and after rook a8 oh yes does anybody
see what i have in mind it's i i love
these moves because they're they don't
look that beautiful but they're they're
cool knight b2 exactly you drop the
knight back
and you win the pawn on a4 nothing
special but it's it's nice we win a
second pawn
and uh we win the game okay so 10
seconds for black it's over
cool stuff
yeah only 28 moves this was a pretty
short game no but i don't know why our
opponent is like
just not even moving
okay great
so the catalan right the catalan you can
enter the catalan through a bunch of
different move orders like you can play
g3 first
you can play one knight f3 and two g3
right everybody should understand that
the catalan arises through a gazillion
different move orders
and the catalan is characterized by this
position this move g3 in this position
is actually what the catalan is
so
the first thing that makes the catalan
almost impossible to study
is just the amount of different setups
that black has you might think oh i play
the night of like i you know i'm not
afraid of a couple of different lines
this isn't a couple black has about 15
different viable setups continuations
lines
in every one of these positions like
here
there are a bunch of alternatives
there's dc dc itself isn't just one line
it's a million lines
no i don't know i know maybe like three
percent of catalan theory
so here there's check
there is
a6 there is knight c6 there is c5 bishop
b4 all of these have over a thousand
games on opening explorer
bishop d7 is huge
c6 is huge and of course there's bishop
e7 which transposes into what i'm about
to tell you so other than that
there is bishop before check
c6 and c5 and after bishop e7 and
castles
there is c6 here which is a huge line
and there is dc
which is
a line that people couldn't find what to
do against for the longest time and
every one of these lines has to be
studied very carefully and even after dc
queen c2 there is this new move b5 that
icaru has been playing a lot there's the
traditional move a6 there is b6 there is
like
just
it's just an unbelievable amount of
theory but let alone the theory
conceptually it's also ridiculously
complicated like all of these ideas and
concepts that you have to know and you
have to understand how to play down a
pawn when black goes b5
so i'm not really doing a good sales
pitch for the catalan but it's it's a
tremendously complex opening
um
so our opponent played a6 which is a
rare move it's not the best
it's not the best because it allows us
to get the queen out to c2
or i guess it's fine because
i guess it's not the best the way he
played it but if black plays dc here
then it transposes back into the most
popular line of the catalan
which is queen takes c4
now recently the move a4 has become even
more popular than queen takes c4
but the old main line is queen takes c4
b5 queen c2 and bishop b7 and in the old
days like 80s and 90s
almost everybody used to play bishop d2
this is still the main move and as black
almost everybody would play bishop b4
queen c1 and bishop back to b7 and
obviously a ton of games ended in this
repetition
but at some point this line was like all
the rage and kramnik was playing it and
stuff
later on people started discovering
alternatives
alternatives in this position
and then at some point this move c6
became incredibly popular super
computer-ish move i played it with black
so
you know so so the theory of this of the
catalan has evolved through the years
and recently i would say a4 has
overtaken queen takes c4 in popularity
and
i think black has struggled to equalize
against a4 the idea is to prevent b5 of
course
but i think our opponent's first serious
mistake was knight c6 and here i made a
counter mistake
i i didn't realize that knight before
was an idea so if i did
i would probably play the move knight b
to d2 here
and you might say well i don't get how
does that stop this idea with knight b4
well the problem is that you can just
drop the queen back to b1
and if black sort of obstinately goes
for the same line
you probably already have tactics here
with like knight f e5 attacking the rook
in the corner
and then maybe the other knight could
swing out to a5 and then to c6
and this gets really really nasty for
black
so i'm pretty sure that knight bd2 would
have been the most accurate move we
played rook d1
allowing black to resort back to this
idea of taking on c4 and going b5
there's actually two games in the
database here i wonder 2300 oh it's 2400
and 2400 so this position has occurred
in uh in some in some high level games
after knight c3
yeah even knight bd5 has been played
once
and bishop g5 apparently is the novelty
so after bishop g5
i think a critical position arises
and here our opponent made a serious a
series of mistakes that that stems from
not understanding the position
if you understand that the c5 square
is the critical square
then i think you're tempted to play
knight takes c3
now there's also tactics here queen
takes c3 does not work
and the reason it does not work is
because of knight e4 bishop e7 takes
takes and unfortunately you lose the
rook and then the knight evacuates via
b2 so white has to play bc which is less
than desirable because it you know it
damages the pawn structure and what
would you guys propose here for black
what should black do in this position
well
c5 but did you consider dc
yeah actually c5 might be good dc
and now simply
queen c7 and now simply queen c7
and i don't think that white can defend
this pawn
and i think that black is totally fine
so i think this would have equalized c5
and black is fine now maybe white can
play a4 shroom you were suggesting this
move in a different position
yeah bishop d5 here is also probably
fine
yeah bishop d5 here is also probably
fine yeah yeah
yeah so i i i think i made a serious
mistake
in allowing and allowing the move knight
before
and then dc and b5 because our queen
ends up making a gazillion move so we
waste a bunch of tempe
knight c3 bishop g5 so h6
actually helps us do what we want to do
anyway and now another mistake black
definitely has to take with the knight
definitely has to take with the knight
in order to prevent us from getting our
knight to e4
why is that something that black needs
to prevent because if white clamps down
on the c5 square i think we've already
all established the black is much worse
now what would i have done here
probably
we would have played the move knight to
e5 the interesting thing in the catalan
is that it's often a good idea for white
to trade the catalan bishop which sounds
crazy if you hear hear it for the first
time
but look at this c6 square that's a
serious weakness this knight's a big
strength
and white's pieces are just better
placed i mean we're just more active
we're just generally more active so
unless black can get c5 in here which
maybe he can maybe he can maybe this
works dc queen c7
black is
liable to be
quite a bit worse in these types of
positions you know what i'm saying
yeah maybe c5 works
we could also play rook ac one we could
take the calmer approach and improve the
positioning of our rook that's also fine
in case you want
so i think white's slightly better here
but after bishop f694 we are much better
i mean it really that is how big the
difference is when black is not even
close to playing c5 then white is much
much better so after 94 black can never
play c5
we increase our control over the
position of the rook ac one
we put the other knight on e5 and at
this point the pressure almost grows
unbearable bishop d5 queen c2 attacking
c7
and after knight c4 knight takes c4
already black is in huge trouble because
if he had taken with a bishop then i
think we have the simple move b3
for starters bishop d5 and queen takes
c7 snags the pawn
bc we play the movie three this is a
very important move because not only
does it solidify the center but it
prepares the move knight d2 and again if
we had played 92 immediately
then we would have dropped the pawn on
d4 so you prepare it with the movie
three then you move the knight back to
d2 you don't care about the trade of
bishops
you take on c5 we win the pawn
and then queen d2 is a super nice move
it attacks the pawn
attacks the pawn
if a4 then knight b2 wins the other pawn
and if black had played rook a8
we have this very pretty tactic knight
takes a5
queen takes a5 rook takes ca check
overloaded rook and white wins the game
so
so yeah this was this was a pretty nice
introduction to the catalan i think
um
who said there's gonna be one more game
i don't know about that it's it's pretty
late so
there's so much more i could talk about
in the catalan that's why i don't like
these open because i feel like i'm not
really scratching even the surface of
this opening
what about queen d7 as less move
oh instead of knight p2 uh well here
hear black can play a b though what is
your idea
you're not threatening the bishop
so and if you play knight d6 then you
allow queen takes c1
you have to remember this concept
what about knight f4 after rook c1
so we played roxy one here oh
oh look at that suggestion that's super
interesting i didn't see this move
i did not see this move
this
was very interesting now i don't think
that it solves any of black's problems
we still go 95
and this structure is actually not that
bad
and i i think you know this this
structure is already is not that bad
and we're still preventing c5 a great
catch
um and maybe that's maybe that was
black's best chance to play something
like that a question about whether black
can play the catalan structure not
really that there is no equivalent
reverse opening that i know of of course
some of the ideas can be applied but not
the opening itself you might know that
boris average who is a friend of mine
he's a very strong grandmaster he
wrote two very well received books on
1d4 he is considered a catalan expert so
he's basically written the catalan bible
now his his original 1d4 book is kind of
outdated at this point but he's updated
it
and you know if you want to learn the
catalan you want to take the take on the
gauntlet
avrix book is in my opinion
you know the gold standard that's where
you should start but i don't recommend
it i i just if you can be a d4 player
that's fine
but my recommendation under 2200 and
i've made this very clear is the
carlsbad c takes d5 against the queen's
game declined this is my recommendation
officially
um
or or if you want to play the london you
can play the london that's also fine
alright guys
thank you all thanks for hanging out
hope you had a good time
[Music]
you